Hey Wisecrack, Jared again.
Today, we’re talking about a show you’ve
all been requesting for a really long time.
Our favorite scifi nightmare -- Black Mirror.
Black Mirror tackles a variety of issues posed
by technology, and while it may not have a
consistent narrative between episodes, we’ve
noticed one theme that keeps coming back.
Whether the show is tackling virtual reality,
politics, social media, or interspecies erotica,
Black Mirror really loves spectacle.
If watching Black Mirror gives you a sinking
feeling of dread, or disgust, it may be because
this idea of spectacle isn’t science fiction,
but is built into the fabric of our reality.
Welcome to this Wisecrack Edition on the philosophy
of Black Mirror.
And, of course, spoilers ahead.
So what is spectacle?
It’s not just fireworks, pro wrestling or
your drunk uncle at Thanksgiving, it’s really
any kind of compelling visual display.
TV, video games, the internet, real life - all
these things are essentially spectacles.
But if there’s one kind of spectacle that
pervades our daily reality, it’s the kind
that comes through our screens.
If you haven’t noticed, Black Mirror is
obsessed with screens.
The show’s promotional art features a cracked
screen, and, you know, the title is a reference
to this.
The relationship between screen and viewer
is central throughout the show.
In The National Anthem, an on-screen spectacle
mesmerizes a nation, while a performance artist
releases a hostage in broad daylight.
In Nosedive, smartphone screens -- and, uh,
eye screens?
-- Compel everyone to rate their fellow humans just
like one might rate a hipster bar on
Yelp.
In The Waldo Moment a screen literally becomes
a politician, and some of the show’s first
moments visually emphasize the screens surrounding
the British cabinet.
We can better understand Black Mirror’s
screen fixation through the lens of philosopher
Guy Debord.
In the 1960s, Debord suggested that understanding
“spectacle” was critical to understand
society.
In the aptly named “Society of the Spectacle,
Debord wrote that in the decades following
the industrial revolution, images and appearances
had begun to govern the world.
Many of the protagonists in Black Mirror experience
spectacle in their own way.
Bing is immersed by screens in Fifteen Million
Merits.
White Bear turns the justice system into a
literal spectacle of justice.
"Murderer!"
In the National Anthem, the merits of pig
sex are mostly discussed in terms of public
perception.
However, one of
the most illustrative examples is Nosedive,
where a young woman named Lacie, like many
of us, derives her self-worth from her smartphone
- speaking of which, please don’t forget to thumbs
up this video.
According to Debord, "The spectacle is not
a series of images, but a social relationship
between people that is mediated by images".
To over simplify: we’ve been numbed by years
of advertising and mass culture and, because
of that, live shallow, disconnected lives.
In Nosedive, What we’re going to call “yelp
for people” has reengineered society into
a new class system based on popularity, which
is in turn, based on spectacular social media
profiles and fake kindness.
Lacie constantly does things she otherwise
wouldn’t: she takes photos of food she finds
disgusting and is overly nice to people who
play an accessory role in her life;
"Hope you're having a great night."
"It's pretty good."
all in order to get positive rating on an app which
attributes “objective value" to people.
Nay Nay is putting on a ridiculous show whenever
she opens up a device.
Lacie’s coworker has to be unnaturally kind
and beg for positive ratings.
"They're from the organic stall at the farmer's market."
Nobody is free to be their authentic selves
because, as Lacie says: "
"That's how the f***ing world works!"
People develop relations with their phones
and apps, which in turn develop relationships
with other humans.
In other words, to recap Debord, our relationships
are mediated by images, but in this case,
images delivered by our phones.
For Debord, the more we recognize our own
existence in the terms set forth by the spectacle,
the less we understand our “own existence”
and our “own desires.”
What Lacie wants is simple: a fancy new house.
"We need you around a 4.5"
"4.5"
For that, she needs to boost her social media
score and make good with Nay Nay, her high
school friend who had sex with Lacie’s boyfriend.
In true Debordian fashion, Lacie’s increasing
immersion into spectacle, makes her a hollow
shell of her former self before finally going
cray cray at Nay Nay’s wedding.
Lacie fails in both being herself and being
someone she’s not.
"I'm so honored to be here to see this sh*t. I love you Nay Nay!"
The spectacle has not only defined her desire,
but made her a prisoner to it.
It’s only when Lacie is forcefully removed
from spectacle and thrown in jail that she
seems to find authenticity.
"F*ck you!"
But how did we get here?
How did the society of spectacle take over
the lives of Lacie, Bing, Prime Minister Callow,
and even our own lives?
Debord provides an answer that resonates in
Black Mirror.
Debord argues that spectacle is born when
the economy invades the very fabric of our
social lives.
In Fifteen Million Merits, we see what this
economic invasion looks like as entertainment
dictates every aspect of social life.
Bing pointlessly rides a bike to accumulate
virtual currency he can only spend on necessities,
entertainment, or his, uh, Mii?.
He and everyone else lives in a cube made
with screens, where he constantly receives
pop up ads he has to ignore.
Things that exist outside of this mii-conomy
are frowned upon.
In one telling scene, paper origami is discarded
as garbage because it doesn’t exist in the
circuit of labor and commodities offered by
what I'm going to call...
George Orwell's favorite soul-cycle class.
"I love choosing my own clothes and I love gold. I feel like it really expresses who I really am."
In an attempt to escape the spectacle, Bing
becomes obsessed with authenticity and decides
to do something meaningful for someone else,
namely getting a woman he heard singing in
the bathroom a shot at becoming famous.
But some Simon Cowell wannabe has other plans.
The economic incentive to pimp out Abi outweighs
whatever hopes and dreams she, or Bing, had.
Bing even explicitly reflects on the way that
the economy has infiltrated their lives:
but, as we learn, even dissent becomes a commodity.
Bing gets a lavish apartment, everyone remains
miserable and the spectacle goes on, literally.
This economic invasion of everyday life, for
Debord, happens at a very specific moment:
when “being” becomes “having,” when
who you are is defined by what you have.
This logic is everywhere in our own society:
wearing a Dead Kennedys shirt makes you a rebel,
guzzling pepsi makes you an activist and having
a bumper sticker makes you whatever kind of
pretentious you aspire to be.
Black Mirror follows this logic, but takes
it a step further.
In Be Right Back, a grieving woman purchases
a life-sized avatar of her boyfriend after
he dies.
"I won't bite."
“Having” a relationship replaces “being”
in a relationship.
The shard of glass Bing used to threaten to
kill himself becomes a virtual commodity - “owning”
rebellion replaces “being” rebellion.
The Waldo Moment further explores what happens
when this logic enters the political sphere.
It follows Gwendolyn Harris, an aspiring politician,
and Jamie Salter, a comedian who voices a
foul-mouthed cartoon bear that becomes a global
icon.
The Waldo Moment focuses on the unreality
of politics.
Gwendolyn truly wants to be a politician,
but struggles with the spectacle of it all.
While she seems genuinely concerned with policy,
"I was at least attempting to represent s- well I don't know, not just bullocks to everything."
her campaign is just a show for her future aspirations.
"The way you describe it, it's like you're doing this for a show reel."
"No!"
"So it's good exposure. You're not gonna win, you know you're not gonna win."
Meanwhile, Jamie is a depressed joke-making
nihilist who begrundgingly runs for office.
Except, people seem way too into his message.
Waldo is pure spectacle,
"There's no point in attempting to converse with a cartoon."
"Oooh, converse, your lordship, thy flowery language doth give me a right throbbing bone-on."
his only metric for
success seems to be attention.
"...hey, hey, please Mr. Monroe. Hey, hey, good morning everybody! Why're you ignoring me, Mr. Monroe?
Why're you ignoring me, Mr. Monroe? Mr. Monroe, why're you ignoring me?
And, like any spectacle, it’s pure image
with no substance.
Jamie constantly reminds us Waldo isn’t
real but as it turns out, that doesn’t seem
to really matter.
"Waldo's not real."
"Exactly, that's what you said that really hit home. He's not real, but he's realer than all the others.
Spectacle is bigger than any of its individual
actors, an autonomous system - like if Skynet
decided to only care about cat videos and reality
tv.
And, for the “real” politicians like Monroe,
who have always succeeded via spectacle,
"I think we should have a round of applause for the children. It is fantastic."
they become powerless in the face of a much better
spectacle.
"A career politician, someone else less real than me and I can do this!"
Monroe’s last-minute attempts to appeal
to “real” politics are pointless, because
the spectacle had won long ago.
For Debord, the system gives us competing
spectacles that are nothing more than “vaporous
qualities meant to stimulate loyalty to quantitative
trivialities.”
In other words, just as spectacle compels
Yankees fans to hate Red sox fans, it compels
people to identify with a blue bear who makes
fart jokes.
The system can profit as much from the Yankees
vs Red Sox as it can from Waldo vs the status quo.
"Everyone's pissed with the status quo and Waldo gives that a voice."
"Waldo's a bear."
As with Bing, dissent is a commodity.
"You could roll this out worldwide."
"Like Pringles."
"Absolutely."
Or, as Debord says
So here’s a question: are we heading towards
our inevitable destruction like Black Mirror
imagines?
Well, maybe there's hope.
The show balances its pessimism with San Junipero
in which two women fall in love in a simulated
reality and choose to live there for eternity
instead of accepting death.
In this world, the spectacle of San Junipero isn’t a nightmare, but literally heaven.
Debord wrote The Society of the Spectacle
in the sixties, so he was mostly talking about
the world dominated by television, radio,
movies and mass-advertisement.
He didn’t see or predict the advent of smartphones
or social media, but he certainly foresaw
how they would shape society in a pretty prophetic
way.
What do you think Wisecrack?
Will spectacle drive us to the hellish world
of Black Mirror?
Or are we already there?